second débat tout de suite
volontairement vous le savez décalée de
l'actualité du jour consacré à la
culture ce secteur doit se réinventer
après l'épidémie de covin les aides de
l'état ont permis de tenir de survivre
mais les mois de fermeture
pour les petits théâtres privés
notamment ont énormément de conséquences
aujourd'hui et c'est peut-être le plus
dur qui commence et science fiction
le quartier latin a retrouvé son
animation et le théâtre de la huchette
son public cette institution parisienne
a réouvert ses portes il ya un nom après
six mois de fermeture liée au vide ça
c'est le décor de ce qu'on appelle le
troisième spectacle
le spectacle de création pour franck
desmedt le directeur si les spectateurs
sont effectivement au rendez vous ils
sont beaucoup plus imprévisible ce que
l'on peut constater c'est que au niveau
des réservations ça se fait de plus en
plus ce dernier moment on a de moins en
moins de visibilité sur nos salles alors
on a la chance d'avoir des salles
pleines sur certains spectacles ici on a
trois créneaux de représentation et il
ya des spectacles qui remplissent très
bien mais on a beaucoup moins de
visibilité qu'auparavant moins de
visibilité sur le comportement du public
franck a aussi trouvé difficile de
reprendre la gestion des finances après
les deux ans de coheed ou son théâtre a
survécu sous perfusion des aides de
l'état grâce au fonds d'urgence au
chômage partiel et aux avances sur
loyers force est de reconnaître que les
aides ont été au rendez vous alors après
la certitude demeure sur la reprise sur
le niveau d'activité qu'on aura mais
c'est encore trop tôt pour mesurer
[Musique]
les pertes qu'on a eu on estime à 30 % à
peu près le nombre de gens - qui sont
venus sur la période mais la plus grande
perte yuko vide pour les petites
structures comme celle de franck desmet
a été de ne pas pouvoir dénicher de
nouveaux talents de travail essentiel
qu'on fait d'aller repérer les talents
de les faire sortir et de les produire
au départ alors que évidemment une
structure comme celui là n'est
évidemment économique pour pas rentable
après ce sont les lieux plus importants
qui les récupèrent et qui est qu'il est
qui les font tourner donc on a aussi un
vrai travail de défrichage et on prépare
l'avenir on prépare l'avenir d'aider des
artistes de demain et sans n'a pas pu
faire un rôle qu'il pourra reprendre une
fois que tous les projets artistiques
qui attendaient depuis des mois auront
été diffusées
quelles leçons tirer de cette crise qu
vide pour le monde de la culture comment
se réinventer après c'est confinement à
répétition on en débat tout de suite
avec roselyne bachelot bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ancienne milice de la justice
entr'autres j'ai fait beaucoup de
ministères mais jamais le juste il dit
la justice c'est drôle parce que le
lapsus est intéressant parce qu'on a
beaucoup parlé dans le débat précédent
évidemment la culture
rachid ouramdane bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes chorégraphe directeur de chaillot
théâtre national de la danse et signale
que votre nouveau spectacle corps
extrême est à la fiche du 16 au 24 juin
j'accueille également michel guérin
chroniqueur culturel rédacteur en chef
au quotidien le monde bonsoir via du
siècle par évidemment il est irréaliste
politique est resté à mes côtés roselyne
bachelot ministre de la culture ancienne
mise en culture c'est drôle comme lapsus
l'état et et au soutien de toutes ces
entreprises de ces lieux de culture et
des intermittents du spectacle qu'il
faut il faut le rappeler et c'était ô
combien important est ce que le plus dur
commence maintenant est ce que c'est ce
que vous direz
certainement le plus dur commence parce
que on a été dans une politique de
soutien dans un secteur en souffrance
mais ce secteur est en souffrance de
façon durable parce que il est l'objet
de mutations extrêmement profonde que la
crise qu vidèrent n'a fait qu'accélérer
et d'ailleurs je relisais l'excellent
papier michel guérin sur
le rapport sur les pratiques culturelles
des français qui est paru en 2020 et on
voit que ces transformations
elles sont bien antérieurs à la crise à
la crise qu vidèrent le changement des
pratiques culturelles la vase y ont
littéralement du numérique par exemple
eh bien ces transformations sont à
l'oeuvre depuis très longtemps et le
secteur qui sort de cette crise il est
obligé en quelque sorte d'avaler ses
transformations à à vitesse à vitesse
extrêmement accéléré donc ce secteur il
a besoin le secteur de la culture et
devrait-on dire les secteurs de la
culture parce qu'il ya des choses très
différentes ils ont besoin de soutien il
encore besoin du soutien massif de
l'état mais d'un soutien qui sera pas un
soutien statique qui sera de simplement
compenser une perte financière mais d'un
soutien organisationnel d'un soutien
dynamique pour permettre au secteur de
se transformer et d'affronter ces défis
et michel guérin est ce que
effectivement on risque on peut voir
apparaître la des faillites des
fermetures de deux de théâtre dans les
semaines dans les mois qui viennent on
l'avait déjà annoncé il ya deux en un an
d'un n'a pas vu pour l'instant mais
c'est vrai que là on voit poindre
notamment région notamment sur des
structures moyennes devant des
structures petites notamment des
théâtres de grosses difficultés certains
annoncent qu'ils vont peut-être faire
mais c'est bien en effet comme l'a dit
roselyne bachelot c'est bien que se joue
parce que pendant des mois et des mois
les tailles temps soutient on peut aussi
se poser la question est ce que c'était
bien d'être toujours en soutien à ce
point là parce qu'à un moment on peut
pas continuer comme ça j'imagine pendant
des mois des années et se poser et de
pas se poser la question comme vous le
faites c'est à dire de savoir vraiment
avec les et complet changement de
pratique notamment des jeunes parce que
c'est là que ça se joue beaucoup se joue
à la fois chez les jeunes et chez les
personnes ont dit les seniors c les deux
publics problématique
les premiers dans leur champ jouer les
deux dans leur changement qui sont pas
du tout les mêmes
qu'est-ce que jusqu'où on va te dire
comme ça et un moment cette culture de
sortie est ce qu'elle est vraiment
menacé comment comment y remédier c'est
ça les questions qu'il va falloir se
poser on a vécu une espèce d'euphorie de
retour la paix depuis janvier on voit
qu'en gros pour aller vite alors c'est
bien on va donner il ya les détaillants
qui disent c'est pas vrai partout mais
en gros vous avez entre 30 et 40 % du
public qui ne revient pas alors pour le
loup ce sera à cause des touristes et
pour des lieux ça va être parce que le
cinéma le cinéma c'est le plus
massivement c'est ce que vous dites je
suis facile parce qu'en plus c'est le
secteur on allait tous les chiffres
c'est le seul secteur en avant les
chiffres à la journée près au cinéma
après
on a cassé que les chiffres vous allez
me chez j'en suis sûr en régie fréquenté
cette fréquentation des salles de cinéma
entre janvier et mai de cette année une
baisse de 32 9% par rapport à la même
période
19 évidemment c'est l'année de référence
la vue kardon l'année de wismes pour le
cinéma oui mais
2018 oui mais bon quand même quand même
on en est là et c'est vrai que
économiquement la plupart des chefs
d'entreprises en dehors du secteur de la
culture leur année de référence et 2019
parce que toutes les deux suivantes ont
été totalement biaisé 48% des français
qui déclarent être revenu moins souvent
ou plus du tout au cinéma depuis la
réouverture des salles le 19 mai quels
sont les films les plus menacées par ces
débats et moi si on attendait de réparer
les films du milieu c'est-à-dire les
films qu'on les budgets un peu un peu
moyen c'est ça et en fait ce sont
vraiment les on parle toujours comme ça
en chiffres globaux en donne -30 -40 %
mais il ya un autre phénomène qui est
pour moi encore plus inquiétant c'est
que cette fracture entre allons allons
vite entre les les oeuvres blockbusters
comme on dit les gros films et mais on
peut dire aussi les gros livres on peut
dire aussi les grosses expositions et
les choses plus petit là c'est aussi
c'étaient ses anciens comme phénomène
c'est à dire une forme de
cristallisation vers le public va vers
le gros est de moins en moins vers le
petit ça s'accentue et là on le regarde
on le dernier la les derniers jours au
cinéma où le film avec tom cruise dans
le top gun et le rugueux mais j'ai envie
de dire email accaparent une énorme
partie 1 905 sambi l'entrée du public et
alors on va dire sa patte droite est à
ce point et deux au team suivant qui
arrive en numéro 2 et numéro 3 c'est
pareil c'est la même chose vous demander
ensuite aux libraires libraires vont
vous dire que ces quelques livres un
moment qui voit là ayant surgi
s'accentue en grande partie je pense
parce que les seniors on trouve chez eux
je ne donne pas mon avis là dessus c'est
comme ça
l'équivalent ou venise et six mètres
équivalent avec et c'est une grande
partie senior et l'autre problème est le
printemps des seniors c'est qu'en plus
des ce qu'elle est souvent au spectacle
series y aller 2 3 5 6 fois par mois
alors que les plus jeunes il retourne à
la culture sans aucun problème mais il
retourne à bord ils sont occasionnels et
ensuite ils ne vont voir que des énormes
spectacle et notamment ou musicaux ou
cinéma alors on va évidemment continuer
de détailler tout ça rachid ouramdane
alors ça use c'est une institution il
faut le rappeler théâtre national de la
danse établissements publics dont les
missions sont définies par par l'état
c'est quoi vous votre en jeu au sortir
de cette pandémie est ce que c'est quand
même de faire revenir le public malgré
tout oui oui bien sûr mais un public
transformé 1 j'écoute tout ce qui tout
ce qui vient d'être dit je pense que
pendant un moment effectivement on a
beaucoup misé sur un retour à la normale
avec une certaine conscience de tout ce
qui c'était passé une attention aux
vivants à l'écologie parce que on avait
on avait vécu cette crise sanitaire
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il faut il faut
vraiment admettre que le public s'est
transformé ce qu'on est venu transformer
le quotidien il public on a créé des
nouvelles habitudes on en parlait avant
d'arriver sur le plateau le télétravail
ça crée un nouveau rythme dans la
semaine cd le bea sur la pratique des
écrans dont on entend beaucoup parler le
besoin de plein air aussi les pratiques
de plein air qui tout d'un coup se sont
démultipliés donc c'est vrai que de
retourner dans un espace clos et en même
temps parallèle de ça on a vu une
jeunesse bravait les autorités à des
rassemblements sauvages donc ce besoin
d'être en communauté de se rassembler de
se réunir reste la demeure là donc
aujourd'hui on s'interroge
au travers de ce prisme là c'est à dire
comment
les spectacles les expériences qu'on
propose répondent vont tenir compte de
ces de ce public transformé c'est
l'éternelle question centrale me
semble-t-il c'est est-ce que l'offre
culturelle doit se calquer justement sur
la demande du public ou est-ce qu'il
faut proposer une offre culturelle qui
influent et qui influencent le public
pour peut-être les ramener à vous voyez
c'est toujours bon on se pose aussi la
question de télévision est ce qu'il faut
offrir au public ce qu'ils veulent ou
plutôt offrir un programme qui éveille
les consciences sur les deux regarde et
se dispense avec top gun c'est
intéressant parce que finalement top gun
offre à nouveau mode de cinéma et des
nouvelles salles bon top gun c'est cette
construction stroboscopique avec des
avec des salles en immersion avec
différents types d'immersion cgr c'est
le modèle c'est le modèle imax mais où
on a une autre une autre sans assurance
ça veut pas dire qu'en fait que des
films à grand à grands pas des films de
guerre des films aussi on peut très bien
faire un film intimiste avec ces
nouvelles technologies et donc il faut
se dire on va faire du cinéma mais il
faut aussi s'adapter aux goûts du public
on va pas amener les gens avec des
chaînes aux pieds dans les salles de
cinéma il faut aussi que l'ensemble du
secteur se disent il ya de la réalité
virtuelle ya de la réalité augmentée il
ya ya d'autres modes de communication il
faut il faut le faire ce que vous avez
fait à chaillot par exemple avec de la
réalité virtuelle avec blanca nice était
intéressant on nie pas vous pestez aussi
vous tester aussi cela et et jeu ça peut
amener un nouveau public oui c'est sûr
mais quand vous le disiez ça ça grossit
le trait de choses qui étaient déjà là
en réalité et faut pas se perdre et
c'est pas répondre à une attente du
public c'est observer la façon dont il
se comporte et faire en sorte que les
oeuvres donc défendre des artistes les
contenus viennent rencontrer ses
pratiques ses contrats au devant des
publics même s'il vient plus dans les
salles c'est à dire ceux par exemple
s'est passé j'ai rêvé des spectacles
hors les murs du hors les murs parce que
c'est l'explosion qu'hollande inconnu
pour respecter les les gestes barrière
pendant toute cette crise a été une des
propositions km et d'une si tu y en a
toujours eu le désordre digital y en a
toujours eu c'est juste que tout d'un
coup elles ont pris le premier plan et
on a créé une habitude mais je pense
qu'on est en train de vivre ce que
souvent on vit quand il ya une
transformation dans le monde de l'art
l'arrivée de la photographie en a
longtemps pensé que ça allait être la
fin de la peinture ça a été le cas à
l'arrivée du du cd cela mordu vini s'est
on est dans ces moments de
repositionnement entre l'usager et la
production artistique donc voilà il faut
mais effectivement il ya un mouvement
des artistes à opérer et des réseaux de
diffusion on voit beaucoup beaucoup
d'initiatives prendre des expériences
augmenté non ce qu'on constate quand
même c'est que il ya les valeurs sûres
c'est vrai mais pas que on sent aussi
que ce qui fait communication
aujourd'hui c'est les communautés n'est
pas uniquement le pouvoir de
communication de la structure qui qui
offrent le contenu artistique culturel
et et on voit bien qu'il ya une
une envie d' expérience nouvelle et que
très vite on a des épiphénomènes sur des
choses qui sont pas des têtes d'affiché
mais qui sont des nouvelles expériences
et cette notion de nouvelles expériences
avec les objets les expositions les
spectacles quand elles sont accompagnées
d'une balade un peu d'originalité sur
l'avant la presse sur son format là je
je voyais le metteur en scène thomas
joly en ce moment qui propose une pièce
de 12 heures 24 heures c'est
alors qu'on pourrait y avoir 24 heures
qui a encore envie d'y aller voilà c'est
ça aussi promouvoir ses tibias les
réseaux peut-être si vous voulez toucher
des communautés et pour amener public en
utilisant leurs outils oui su faire
confiance au public quand il déniche la
pépite et quand ils partagent
l'expérience nouvel essai le c1 des
prismes à voir mais c'est un vrai débat
parce que
vous parlez de d'aller chercher le
public c'est la notion de l'excellence
de l'audace et puis à côté de ça des
impératifs de gestion et ces questions
là elle se pose que ce soit dans des
clubs privés évidemment mais où tout
dans la culture pic pour lecture
publique ou dans des villes comme devil
finance un théâtre et des impératifs de
gestion et prennent parfois de plus en
plus de place et les impératifs de
gestion ne sont pas du tout les mêmes
dans les lieux publics les lieux privés
aussi si villa le rappeler le théâtre
privé je crois qu'ils avaient aussi un
public peut-être plus âgé que le théâtre
public c'est aussi les questions de
tarifs d'histoire de culture enfin peu
importe mais ils sont soit aussi à -30
35% et souvent ils font des spectacles
qui avait déjà marché avant la pandémie
c'est à dire il n'y a pas d'énorme
création dans le cadre privé en ce
moment quoi qu'on en pense un c'est pas
le sujet et je reprends la question des
crs coloris c'est que ça ne finisse pas
par tahrir finalement l'audace et la
créativité pour
vous posiez la question dans d'ailleurs
dans cet article dont je parle et vous
disiez en début de tout début de
l'article
finalement les les subventions d'état
alors pas les crédits publics état et
collectivités territoriales sont
massivement tournés vers la culture
patrimoniale la culture dont bourdieu
dégoût la définissez comme légitime à ce
que vous appelez patrimoniale c'est à la
blue hill à conakry a surclassé cieux
les musées ou
les citoyens est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on
peut flécher les crédits de la puissance
publique uniquement sur certain en tout
cas c'est l'audience sur vous pour dit
laquelle la question de facilitation qui
va se poser d'autant qu'on va arriver là
à la première génération
qui arrive à l'âge d'aller au spectacle
jandira les 16 18 20 ans et qui n'aura
connu que le numérique mais sérieux
baraqueville essentiellement tik tok et
qui le sont chez réseau social qui
acquise aux soins aux tic toc s'avèrent
des vidéos dans la seconde et qui ont la
formation enfin c'est l'habitude de
consommation culturelle si la vie de la
musique en streaming
du réseau social et une génération qui
n'est quasiment jamais sortie et ça veut
pas dire qu'ils sont pas cultivés c'est
sûr que c'est parce que je suis en dit
long une autre culture fait différemment
je vois par exemple j'ai avant de venir
j'ai appelé deux principaux responsables
de festivals rock de l'été les vieilles
charrues et puis les eurockéennes de
belfort qui arrive bientôt au caire ils
me disent sur les grands tête d'affiche
ça va aller ça remplit et pour tout ce
qui est découverte et en général c'était
le jeune public qui venaient parce que
le festival c'est souvent la première
rentrée à la culture pour les jeunes ils
se sentent moins intimidés et d'aller un
festival je parle pas des dissiper une
langue peut-être plus facile mais plutôt
que d'aller dans une salle dite installé
etc ils se sentent plus chez eux quoi
bon eh ben ils disent et jeunes là on en
voit il voit les réservations sais c'est
pas fini les gens se réservent au
dernier moment aussi mais quand même
qu'il soit assez inquiet pour toutes
leurs parties découvertes qui ne voyait
pas il ya deux trois ans être aussi peu
rempli en disant quand même que dans les
pratiques culturelles les festivals sont
non seulement une pratique qui se
maintient et on le voit dans
l'ajustement cette étude sur les
pratiques culturelles des français c'est
cette une est une des pratiques qui
vraiment a le vent en poupe le festival
est d'ailleurs on a vu à quel point chez
les jeunes la suppression des festivals
des concerts debout a vraiment été a
vraiment été une souffrance une sorte de
communion quand on va aux vielles
charrues l'on naît on est vraiment on
est vraiment très vite passionné mais je
suis sûr que stromae qui ouvre les
vieilles charrues le 14 juillet je ne me
fais pas d'illusions ce qui est génial
70 ce plaisir de revenir au théâtre ou
au concert et partager ça c'était quand
même et ça c'est assez intéressant il ya
quand même 15 % des jeunes
qui sont uniques non il ya quinze pour
cent des gens pardon qui sont sur une
culture numérique exclusive qui ne vont
en rien d'autre ni musée ni de rien et
que c'est majoritairement des gens moins
de 40 ans et ça faut pas se faire qu il
n'y jamais un livre il faut pas se faire
d'illusions quand on n'a pas lu un livre
avant 40 ans tu ne sais pas où je les
mythes palais l'histoire de la rolex
quand on n'a pas lu un livre avant 40
ans je vous garantis qu'on ne lira pas
50 donc là il ya des changements qui
sont tendance à a évidemment à grossir
grossir rachid ouramdane sais c'est quoi
la moyenne d'âge
du spectateur de chaillot internationale
de la danse aujourd'hui il est en train
de réjeanne hier même s'il reste élevé
ses 50 ans mais en fait ces dernières
années il ya une jeune que j'ai une
émission de télévision je peux vous le
décès des jeunes pour les moyennes en
soi mais c'est pas de gêne pour une
moyenne non parce que
je lisais aussi votre article sur le
vieillissement
du public en musique classique par
exemple là pour le coup sûr le théâtre
national de la danse on a plutôt en
rajeunissement c'est que aujourd'hui on
a ce qu'on appelle le public jeune ses
27 % là où il ya 15 ans étaient 12% donc
il ya plutôt ce mouvement là mais est ce
que vous savez d'expliquer est ce que
c'est une programmation qui a changé
quand vous l'expliquer il ya plusieurs
au delà du coc vie d'un c'est parce que
c'est un mouvement qui a été amorcé plus
tôt non il ya
de plus en plus une attention au corps
qui est fait aux plaisirs du mouvement
tout à l'heure vous citiez tik tok 70%
des contenus de tik tok c'est des
contenus dans c'est un donc un
c'est non ce rapport au corps je crois
qu'ils continuent depuis les années 68
de se libérer peut-être d'une certaine
façon avec ed des grands phénomènes
après ça veut pas dire que ça ça nous
amène à un des auteurs à des artistes à
des chorégraphes on parle de pratiques
donc non sans les spectateurs c'est
aussi la question je vais vous poser est
ce que et je fais pas mon goût me
rendais en disant ça mais est ce que le
fait de devoir de la danse des contenus
dans ces sur tik tok qui dure je le
rappelle la seconde est ce que ça
prépare à aller voir un spectacle de
danse
peut-être pas seulement à chaillot mais
un spectacle de danse plus long de m en
tout je vais vous donner un exemple et
une compagnie le ballet national de
marseille la horde à partir de ce
phénomène là ils ont identifié
effectivement sur les réseaux sociaux il
y avait une dans ce qu'on appelle le jam
star elle qui se pratique uniquement par
envoi de très courtes vidéos format
réseaux sociaux donc c'est quelque chose
qui est très frontal qui est pensé pour
une caméra ça se danse un peu de profil
une sorte de nine gisci de notre siècle
est en fait ils ont décidé d'organiser
tout un spectacle autour de ça en
réunissant ces personnes sur un peu et
en fait c'est un spectacle qui a une vie
délirante qui avec a fait le buzz parce
que c'est c'est là où ce que je disais
tout à l'heure laissons le temps aux
artistes de se repositionner avec les
cultures du mouvement avec les cultures
dites adultes de l'époque avec les codes
de l'époque pour pouvoir inventer des
nouvelles écritures et sa et sas à
crédit on voit même apparaître des corps
et il ya des chorégraphes qui ont qui
sont vraiment apparu pendant cette crise
qu vite dans leurs capacités qu'ils
avaient à répondre à ces outils-là mehdi
kerkouche par exemple qui est un
chorégraphe aussi qui a produit cette
vidéo virale pendant le confinement
aujourd'hui à une capacité à mobiliser
des publics à ouvrir à d esthétique
urbaine voguing to work etc c'est on est
dans un moment les choses se
repositionne mais clairement clairement
je ne pense pas qu'il faille y voir
comme antinomiques le monde du digital
et le mans dur il ya ce besoin d'être
ensemble vous l'avez évoqué les besoins
de concert maintenant c'est comment
comment on va quoi quel chemin on va
inventer pour à nouveau revenir à ses
oeuvres là qui vont être des oeuvres
métamorphose et je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de voir le plateau comme on l'a
vu jusqu'à il ya encore trois ans il ya
maintenant une mixité dans les dents les
pratiques dans les expressions j'ai
voulu puisque il est de tradition de
faire à l'entrée d'une présidence de ma
présidence européenne du conseil des
ministres la culture me suis dit je vais
pas leur faire l'éternel concert de
musique symphonique tout le monde en a
ras-le-bol d'ailleurs on écoute de moins
en moins la musique classique y avait un
temps c'était 9% des français c'est
maintenant 6 % et chez les jeunes c'est
2% j'ai fait un spectacle de de danse et
de cirque avec la compagnie xy que vous
connaissez et chorégraphié
je suis bien mais ça a eu un succès fou
l'ailé les ministres et les
fonctionnaires de bruxelles avait dit
mais c'est ce spectacle est sensationnel
et parce que ça sam x du cirque et de la
danse classique si l'on peut pas
classique la danse wii classique et les
gens ont soif aussi de sa de se
décloisonner on aime le cirque on va
peut-être venir à la danse par s'appuie
par la danse on va aller au théâtre à
prix d'un billet est la première
obstacles de non je crois pas de la
venue d'un citoyen non je crois pas non
à des partis je savais qu'il ya eu le
rapport du centre national du cinéma
possède savoir pourquoi le public ne
revenez pas il y avait quatre cinq
raisons il y avait le prix ni billets
alors c'est vrai que je pense qu'en des
périodes un peu d'incertitude
sajoo et après il y avait aussi une
raison c'était vous parlez on peut les
voir les raisons pour lesquelles les
français sont parvenus au cinéma on va
les voir s'afficher comme d'habitude
d'aller au cinéma le prix du billet est
arrivé il ya aussi l'inquiétude famille
à vis des raisons qui fait un peu tabou
et personne ne parlait trop ça c'est les
films sont en perdant alors évidemment
il jugeait des juges et des fibres
bonne et ça m'arrive de partir 45e billy
jugé pas l'avouer mais ça m'arrive en
tout cas pour le sait n'a rien à voir là
c'est le roi du cinéma sarine avec la
danse ou même des expositions c'est
c'est simple c'est quand même l'art ou
[Musique]
pour certains films en tout cas pas pour
top gun la différence entre l'écran
domestique elle est confinée panne et de
cinéma n'est pas énorme toujours
sa raison même quand même plus de 20
mètres de longueur et plus de 15 mètres
de hauteur
les télés ont dit les clauses générales
il ya des films qui voit avec ce genre
de on pouvait avoir avec la formule 3d
il avoue avoir des sièges qui sont sûrs
avec des vérins qui bouge et vous avez
le vent vous avez les honneurs non il ya
des choses qu'il faut parfois attention
à dire il faut
être obsédé par ce que veut le public
allait chercher que de faire que ce qui
veux c'est jouer c'est très dangereux il
faut assez calme il faut étudier les
choses jeu pendant que j'ai regardé la
fin je connais la programmation de
chaillot je trouve que c'est vraiment un
mix assez remarquable dans ce programme
des choses très attractive et des choses
un peu plus compliqué est quoi ca ils
font attention ils sont voilà et la
plupart des lieux font font font la même
chose la difficulté ça va être en effet
quand même pour un certain type d'oeuvre
qui sont pas simples et en fait et je
vois pas pourquoi il faudrait accusé la
france à deux lieues de toute fin qu'on
va dire ça soit les pompiers des
problèmes des jeunes qui disent qu'ils
ne vont pas d'abord ils seront pas
obligés d'y aller à ils y arrivent au
foot 1 ne devront pas ce que c'est bien
d'aller au foot ou pas etc mais c'est
pas le rôle je pense aussi de faire
l'icm ans du social je dirais y aillent
à l'école pour ça il ya d'autres lieux
je pense que lui sert de la culture et
cei se bat pour développer d'autres
publics les lieux culturels ce bal
posséderait d'autres publics c'est pas
simple et il faut pas soin et tout le
monde y gagne elle a lancé sa saison le
prix c'est hocine c'est aussi un alibi
parce que je les ai vus sur le perron
dit le père assez cher c'est moins cher
qu'un seul cas un concert de rap ans
allez on va parler un peu
de politique laetitia vous dit que la
culture c'est une rarement une priorité
du personnel politique en tout cas une
grande oubliée la campagne électorale
écoutez j'ai regardé la séquence
présidentielle puisque nous y avons
participé et puis celles qui s'annoncent
les élections législatives est ce que je
ne vais pas vous poser la question à
vous parce que bien sûr que vous le
savez mais enfin je vous demander de
faire un petit test quand vous quitterez
ce plateau vous allez dans la rue et
autour de vous vous posez la question à
la personne qui passe la première est ce
que vous pouvez me citer une mesure
prônée par au moins un des douze
candidats ils étaient douze à la
présidentielle concernant la culture bon
bah écoutez je pense que quasiment
personne n'est capable de vous citer une
mesure pourquoi alors je propose
plusieurs hypothèses il me semble que la
réponse étant sans doute la conjonction
de tout bas d'une part parce que les
candidats n'ont pas fait de la culture
visiblement un un cheval de bataille
dans leurs campagnes ensuite les médias
ont été écrasés c'est vrai par
l'actualité internationale la guerre en
ukraine et puis au niveau national le
pouvoir d'achat et puis il ya aussi une
faible mobilisation du milieu de la
culture dans en tout cas la séquence
présidentielle
à part vous l'avez sans doute vous la
vidéo de anna mouglalis sur un peu à la
façon baron noir pour la primaire de la
gauche qui a été un cuisant échec
bon bah finalement le monde de la
culture ne sait pas plus mobilisés que
cela pour la présidentielle alors on
peut dire encore une mesure qui revient
mais à chaque fois c'est le pass culture
là il ya une vraie popularité
et ce à deux millions de jeunes pass
culture mois on m'arrête dans la rue il
ya des gamins qui m'arrêtent dans la rue
pour me dire merci sur le pass culture
c'est assez c'est assez incroyable
300 euros à dépenser en deux ans et 500
heures c'est 500 euros en tout 300 euros
à 18 ans et 200 euros avant des
pratiques accompagnées la séquence
présidentielle qui n'a pas eu des
développements et le développement du
pass culture est aussi un oeil et bardé
séparé selon lui la risée de la mesure
il ya eu la seule il ya une autre mesure
kaka a marqué les esprits dans le
programme des manades macron
c'est la redevance absolue bien sûr
parce que emmanuel macron a quand même
présenter son projet culturel c'était
aux docks d'aubervilliers début mars et
bien sûr il y avait tout de suite cette
taxe delà de l'art de la suppression de
la taxe de la conférence publique le cap
mais finalement ça a été sous un angle
économique
on n'a pas vraiment compris la portée
culturelle de cette de cette mesure
c'était pour dire aux français votre
porte monnaie va être
la culture et de la communication donc
on est sur le coup et c'est vrai qu
emmanuel macron a quand même regretter
un certain nombre de mesures notamment
la défense de la liberté d'informer il a
vraiment insisté sur cette liberté
d'informer sur la poursuite des
commandes publiques dans le milieu
artistique et puis l'investissement dans
les métavers européen ça il n'a pas
encore vraiment développer mais pendant
la campagne c'est vrai qu'il a énoncées
c'est un mot rapide des législatives est
ce que la culture il ya plus de place
non on va juste noter une petite
tentative de la nuque voilà parce que ce
soir est organisé un concert à lille
promue par les a soumis dont adrien
catelet
on y est le sébasto populaire c'est ce
soir à 19h au théâtre sébastopol de
lille ouverture des portes à 18 heures
avec plusieurs concerts françois schmitt
lénine renaud les un sous sol hubert
félix thiéfaine ça va être une soirée
magnifique on vous attend nombreuses
nombreux c'est gratuit venez avec vos
amis en famille on vous attend à partir
de 18h début de l'évènement à 19 heures
à tout à l'heure on parler d'autre chose
que des queues de la nuit place
la première des vailhés c'est pour ça
que je pose une question gaza s'est fait
rater mon pied parce que je me demandais
si ces artistes allait faire basculer le
vote et j'allais vous proposer qu en
toute impartialité nous attendions
dimanche le résultat nous surprendre à
l'origine je peux quand on est ministre
de la culture est ce que c'est c'est
compliqué de peser dans les arbitrages
c'est quand vous êtes arrivée rue de
valois sightings des premières réactions
que j'ai lu bon voila et là elle a de
l'expérience du poids politique elle va
pouvoir peser sur les biens sur le sujet
du poids politique ege peser sur les
arbitrages j'ai obtenu des contrats
arbitrage souviens d'un temps en
particulier sur une plan de relance ou
la culture il n'était pas forcément
prévu ils y étaient prévus mais pas au
niveau que j'estimais décent et je suis
monté au créneau et j'ai gagné mon
arbitrage et la partie du plan de
relance consacré à la part la culture
est passé de 500 millions à 2 milliards
et ça c'est un arbitrage qui obtenu que
j'ai obtenus et c'est pas le seul bien
sûr il ya eu bien sûr que j'ai des
choses c'est qu'on peut on parle des
aides exceptionnelles noter non mais
nous oublions qu'ovide le budget 2022 de
la culture est excellent pour connaître
ses élèves actuellement excellent alors
le quoi qu'il en coûte version culture
m'entends les tout de suite avec
jonathan
riez rebond soir jonathan
bienvenue d'état qui est venue au
secours on l'a dit dédé des
professionnels du secteur oui vous venez
d'en parler à l'instant madame bachelot
en septembre 2020 l etat met la main au
portefeuille dans le cadre du plan de
relance post co vide et sur un plan
global de 100 milliards et bien il y
aura finalement deux milliards au lieu
des 500 millions qui était prévu qu'ils
vont être mis sur la table pour la
culture alors ces découpes et de cette
manière c'est 1,6 milliard en réalité
qui vont être débloqués pour la période
2021 2022 et ensuite 400 millions
restant sous forme d'investissements
d'avenir pour 2021 à 2025 le secteur
culturel il faut vous l'avez rappelé 1
il était quasiment même à l'arrêt total
entre mars 2020 et mai 2021 il avait
bien besoin d'être aidé un titre
d'exemple j'ai relevé ces chiffres de la
cour des comptes qui avait calculé que
la crise sanitaire avait en 2020 fait
perdre 2 154 millions au musée et côté
cinéma par exemple le chiffre d'affaires
des distributeurs s'étaient effondrées
de 70% et aujourd'hui on en est où
comment cette manne à telle était
répartie alors là je vous cite les
derniers commune le dernier communiqué
du ministère de la culture en date de
février de lune 2022
75 % des crédits ont déjà été alloués à
date oui vous allez les voir ils vont se
détailler sur l'écran 614 millions pour
le patrimoine 426 millions pour la
musique et le spectacle vivant 113
millions pour l'emploi artistique et
enfin 428 millions pour les filières
culturelles dites stratégiques presse
livres ou encore cinéma la cour des
comptes qui n'a pourtant pas le
compliment facile avait reconnu le rôle
essentiel du ministère lors de la crise
sanitaire mais un compliment ne sait-on
déjà une petite pique il est magistral
cambon ont déploré que la rue de valois
devienne un guichet distribution des
milliards efficace certes mais sans
possibilité de contrôle a posteriori
donc les caler les sages réclame
désormais un dispositif d'évaluation de
ces crédits a posteriori ce qui
s'annonce un peu difficile et c'est
aussi ce que réclame le scénar écouter
vraie difficulté pour nous et là je
bascule dans mon rôle de sénateur c'est
d'avoir le contrôle quand on parle du
contrôle du gouvernement le contrôle
exacte de la répartition de ces sommes
et sur une somme comme celle de 2
milliards vous imaginez bien que c'est
pas aussi simple que ça c'est donc là
dessus qu'on veut avoir une parfaite
traçabilité des choses et notamment
d'ailleurs dans le ce qu'on appelle le
dernier kilomètre c'est à dire là où il
ya le ruissellement si j'étais un peu
taquin le ruissellement le plus fin de
savoir comment le milieu de la culture a
pu profiter de cette de cette masse
financière conséquente voilà et vous le
disais aussi un l'argent ne fait pas
tout je reprends un terme que j'ai
entendu dans les coulisses juste avant
de venir vous disais le secteur culturel
et spectacles vivants notamment rentrer
en terrain inconnu et ben en fait c'est
exactement ça la culture doit composer
maintenant avec des nouveaux usages et
peut-être même des nouvelles habitudes
merci beaucoup merci à jonathan d'y
aller je revendique cela parce que dieu
sait si dans ce pays on dit finalement
on est dans un truc technocratique on
vous demande des dossiers mal flat pour
remplir des formulaires qui pendant ce
temps là le secteur a crevé et moi j'ai
volontairement dit on va faire des
procédures allégées on est en situation
d'urgence il y aura peut-être à la marge
quelques-uns qui en avaient pas
forcément
d'accord on récupérera sa après on l'a
fait d'ailleurs mais vous savez quand il
ya des gens qui sont en train de se
noyer on n'est pas en train de repeindre
la bouée de sauvetage eux aux aléas
excusez moi mais au delà d'un des faits
je pense que je joue jusqu'à des données
va être compliqué je crois que la vraie
question c'est de savoir à l'avenir
quelles sont les institutions les lieux
qui sont sans un modèle économique
viable ou pas c'est ça la vraie question
qui va se poser est ce que on fait pas
le bilan de votre passage au ministère
mais quand même je peux pas ne pas vous
poser cette question est-ce que ça
paraît quand même été globalement
frustrant et à se dire il ya eu trois
confinement g
sont bien bien moi qui je sais quand
même un paradoxe moi qui fais partie des
des cultureux entre guillemets qui
sortent tous les soirs dans la vie
normale je suis minizoo la culture
c'est un peu c'est c'est vraiment un
paradoxe
non ce que j'ai voulu d'abord j'étais en
mission commando je les considérais
comme ça vingt-deux mois 6 182 jours
pour pour sauver pour sauver la culture
ce que nous avons fait un partout il ya
des structures qui en ferme et je vois
dans le cinéma on n'avait pas une seule
salle de cinéma qui a fermé enfin le le
têt le tate modern à londres a licencié
40 % de son personnel n'y a pas un
licenciement dans nos structures
publiques etc c'est quand même assez
assez extraordinaire et puis j'ai voulu
aussi que les choses continuent je ne
n'ai pas fait que de l'urgence on a fait
des textes sur la protection le droit
d'auteur
la chronologie des médias on a on a fait
le décret qui a qui fait qu'on les
plateformes vont financer la création
cinématographique et audiovisuelle on a
fait une vraie politique de restitution
d'oeuvres sur les biens spoliés
ou juifs ou sur les biens spoliés à
cause de la colonisation
vraiment on affronte j'ai essayé j'ai
voulu préparer l'avenir et puis surtout
ce plan france 2030 préparer le secteur
à à cette révolution ce tsunami
numérique
là on est en train de faire on est en
train de faire ce boulot et ma
successeur à aura à mettre tout ça en
musique enfin cij pardon mais en oeuvre
parfois en musique et c'est un travail
absolument fascinant aller dans ce ce
débat j'aurais quand même aussi faire un
peu de promotion pour votre spectacle et
on va dire les choses très clairement
rachid ouramdane corps extrêmes on va
voir quelques images sera à la fiche du
16 au 24 juin chaillot puisque
l'objectif d'un débat comme celui là
c'est aussi donner envie aux
téléspectateurs de retourner dans l'est
dans les salles qu'est ce qu'on va
qu'est ce qu'on va découvrir expliquez
moi un peu ce que vous avez voulu
montrer raconte
scène c'est un projet qui est né pendant
le confinement bon même s'il occupait
depuis un moment c'est un projet qui
réunit des des sportifs de l'extrême des
voltigeurs
nathan paulin qui a été très médiatisée
dernièrement il a battu un nouveau
record et les parties du mont saint
michel non en fait ce qui m'intéressait
c'était de voir comment ces personnes
qui mettent en jeu leur corps de façon
extrême comment ils peuvent nourrir
comment ils peuvent nous raconter
autrement la façon dont il
autrement qui nous sommes parce qu'en
fait je pense que c'est ça c'est leur
devoir des personnes qui poussent ces
limiers qui repousse les limites de
cette façon là c'est on peut on peut
penser que ces aventures et qui joue un
peu avec la mort qui sont un peu foufou
puis finalement réalité quand on les
écoute je n'en pensais d'abord des
personnes qui qui qui s'interroge sur
nos limites de façon très humble qui
tente de le partager donc voilà ce qu
extrême c'est un jeu de mot avec sports
de l'extrême et surtout ce à quoi ça
nous renvoie c'est une sensibilité
extrême et pas t'en as des as décor
surpuissant ou des cornes dont certains
des artistes sont ceux que vous avez
invité au moment du lancement de la
présidence française européenne si
beaucoup mr si à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat c'est